here we go
quick breakdown
64 players 65 players now 1806 average
rating time handicapped warzone kings
here we go
tough start to this tournament
let's go here 2017
a non-mover to start again
no this is a mover
whoa what's up with the queen
what's going on with that queen get out
of there
they're trying to get my queen
let's open this up i'm gonna hit the
queen
the bishop's trapped i should have
trapped it
it's freed up now i want to get knight
here
let's do it right now
and i want to get to this square somehow
queenside castle rook to c8 soon
my bishop is uh
gonna get beat up
this pawn is falling
i get this in i'm on that uh rook and i
want to just grab this c3 pawn
knight here i think
is a good idea
right now
can i get that king
otherwise there's a fork maybe
i got the queen mate in one threat
one threat right here
are they going to resign
come on what do we have they resign back
to tournament
whoa
oh man
only a minute and a half
cap
big game as usual
oh oh oh oh we're having sicilian land i
can't move i can't move why am i not
moving
okay bishop e3
uh let's defend like this and there's
gonna be a problem here isn't there
stuff is gonna get hit
i get this and stay on these uh dark
squares
dark squares actually i should play
bishop there
um
there's something bad that's gonna
happen here
really really soon
really really soon i think
i need to get over here i have to oh
i gotta take oh i'm dead i'm dead
or am i can i ha do i have this or
something
i just barely saw that move is it
working
um that night is gonna kill me
i pin that knight and then do what come
over here
i want to get rid of that knight
i get rid of that knight
it's going to be forks and stuff
oh light square bishop
what's the clock situation
over here i could play back or something
can i get that pawn
um
i'm going to try this
is this working
uh it's not really working is it
it might be actually
somehow i have coordination
i have coordination here
work right here and then
pawn push
ah
i missed that
can i get these pawns pushing
i'll just push here push here a couple
more times
clock
i don't have any time
i have no time i have no time
oh barely barely i need to get that last
pawn it was a draw oh
man
do you hear my mouse
oh my goodness my mouse needs to go back
into
training oh man is he slow
i have the slowest mouse around
oh my goodness i'm playing with a
wounded mouse right here how do you how
do you win a game with the wounded mouse
oh man
he is so wounded
i don't even know how he does it
unbelievable that mouse
way to go logitech
logitech you know what i meant
grab that rook and run home night
whoa an inbetweener
my dark square bishop
coming up
kill the dark square bishop
oh they're gonna push here i knew it was
coming
uh
let's kill that
let's no they're on my bishop
let's do this
ah man i had something so much better
let's take here
get out of there night
upon push right here before it's too
late
okay this is scary this is very
scary oh hit the knight
it's very scary very very scary
oh no matter what i play rook check here
you know you want to take that guy don't
you
or do you
is everything working if i go here
13 seconds
come on don't you dare lose this
i'm on the queen and the rook
i'm on the night
uh oh
uh-oh the king's running for the hills
he's running for the hills oh sneaky
checks another sneaky check with the
queen
no don't you dare try and run away
how much time
back to tournament they're down on time
20
20 17 i have six
mule train
another
beast let's go alpin you can do it
oh i didn't mean to do that
that was a mouse slip again my mouse is
so
bad
i'm blaming everything on my mouse
oh i gotta try something sneaky very
very sneaky
i don't even know if this is working i
gotta give it a shot though
i have to give it a shot
what else can you do that knight is
ready to
kill me
okay
i'm gonna take that okay is there
something here there might be
i have the f file
let's just double up here
and then do what
what's the plan after that
get rid of this night
right now and then hopefully have
something over here
grab this pond it's a freebie
hang on let's do this night checks
tricky stuff
tricky tricky stuff i'm gonna try this i
think it works actually i don't know how
i was able to
figure that out in time
but that's mate that's me back to
tournament i'll take it that's a tough
player 30 26.
okay
another
tough cookie right here
let's roll here
uh let's get the night out let's get the
queen here and
well
this is not working
this is not working i need to um
get my pawn up
let's do this before i get killed
before it's too late
um now let's come over here hang on
let's take towards the center
let's chop this up let's see how they
recapture tonight okay i'm gonna go
there
and
let's get development in and play here
i'm not quite sure why
oh man i'm dead
i gotta i gotta do this
whoa that is scary that's a very scary
move to have to deal with right there
and look at how inconvenient it is to
have this bishop controlling this square
very inconvenient
let's try that or just grab the pond
grab the pawn
get out of there
let's try this is this working oh okay
wait wait wait wait wait i get to this
square
barely barely barely working around this
nasty bishop right here on d6 what a
giant pain
you need to go knight i cannot deal with
you anymore
my rook oh my rook my rook my rook
right here no sneaky stuff please
against my king don't let there be
sneaky stuff right here stay
calm oh
man
forks forex forks why didn't i do that
sooner
yes yes yes yes
come on
oh i just dropped that they don't have
any time
though okay everything is glued together
finally
i'm gonna take here go back run king run
don't make mouse slips run with this guy
just take him who cares about that pun
push push push
push again they're down on time back to
tournament 45 42
i have 20
the big bad wolf is back in action right
here
oh always a tough game against the big
bad wolf right here okay
bishop c4 now let's go open sicilian
d4 okay we're having a dragon get ready
to unleash
the beast right here the beast you know
who the beast is
ah i played this wrong
it's going to throw the h-pawn that's
who i meant
he's the beast
open up the h-file that's the plan oh i
got the dragon bishop the dragon bishop
is down he's cooked and now the h pawn
the beast is in action right here let's
go g4 h5 is where i want to be watch out
for queen here
bad things happen oh
give a check they might be scared
that's exactly why i do those moves just
because they might be scared
i could take the night or can i
oh
watch out for mates hang on
i should probably grab here that would
have been nice maybe let's do it now
um let's make sure that knight is here
or off the board i mean
let's block with the bishop i want to
kill the knight very soon
i gotta do that and now the g file is
where it's at he's gotta go he's
definitely gotta go you gotta go
you have to go get out of there
hopefully this is working against wolf
man wolf man i got this pond maybe
give a check oh this is working i think
you know you want to fall for mate
this has to be mate come on you could do
it
give a check of russia i'm on everything
rooks and everything is falling this is
leading to me grab a rook this is
working
this is resign time isn't it resign time
yes back to tournament
61 is in first 59 56 i have 30. uh 18
minutes and change
okay archangel
let's go here more sicilian open
sicilian or otherwise
let's roll here bishop c4 is no longer a
possibility let's strike in the center
and kick that knight around
and play maybe f5 0
f5 maybe
or maybe not
it's not going to be played now that's
not going to be played pawn push here
incoming right now
right now is a good time let's take it
and let's get my rook to a good square
right here is good
and i want to trade light square bishops
let's stay connected here with my
knights
let's go pawn push on c4 coming up
undermine that knight the strongly
placed knight on e4 needs to go
somewhere else light square bishops off
the board and the king is naked
naked king
incoming gonna take with actually my
queen and then
or not okay let's go here i want to get
to this square can we make that happen
please we're making it happen
knight is ready to be a beast take this
bishop and then take the light square
bishop push here to kick the knight
around if he wants to go to e5 how much
time is left let's do this this is what
i was talking about grab here push that
knight around turn him in a pin
and uh hope for the best here maybe get
my majority going that would be nice
this is a three on two majority i have
control over this d5 square that is
important
and the rook right there well
take this pawn it's probably free but
are you gonna take it
they're not okay upon majority is
rolling two on one now instead of a
three on two still rolling and it's
coming to a great halt and my bishop is
staring at b5 oh buddy get this guy
check
back here check bishop improvement
there's no time anything time burners
back to tournament 42
wow somebody has 90 with nine games in
double those points
this guy's having a good tournament 46.
what was the average rating of this
tournament
knight d5 i should have played
let's do this at b5 i want to be
cautious of the b5 move
knight here
sneaky
oh this has to be good this has to be
good
or does it
oh i'm on the rook oh my queen is dead
it's a dead queen no no
no say it isn't so
please don't don't don't don't don't
ah man
there's no way you could save this is
there
there's absolutely no save or is there
tricky nights
watch out for the tricky nights
um
um
crap i don't have anything
you can do it tricky night pawn push
tricky nights tricky nights tricky
nights you know you want to do it right
here i'm down a full queen i don't have
i don't even have a minor piece to play
around with grab a pond i have a pond to
play around with now and a rook sort of
hang on hang on
don't lose faith here
oh no why'd i do that i thought i had a
fork as a follow-up
oh i'm a dead man i'm so
dead oh there's nothing here oh no
is there any hope
you know you want to take the pound your
night do it
i'm on the queen
they gonna see it they are seeing it
i don't have anything
oh this is a disaster
it's a big disaster happening right here
oh
man checks
checks
oh i have nothing how much time
how much time
this is leading to mate
forks where the checks
i got the rook
where's the mate
they're doing this how much time
can i just burn time
time situation time situation
time situation
what i get i want my time
oh don't listen with headphones i have
no idea what i'm gonna come out with
here and i don't know how loud it's
getting but i got that one the time was
my best friend once again
down a queen
down a queen a miraculous comeback
i think that's uh the win of the
tournament right there
i could i could just uh resign every
game i think i'm i'm feeling like i i
right now i feel like i just won the
tournament
take the pawn you know you want to take
them
oh let's come over here keep pins watch
a pun
keep pins and watch a pond is the plan
oh and they're having none of that
okay well my queen needs to do something
else
what is she gonna do
oh man what are you doing queen get out
of my uh neck of the woods here
get out of here man
let's trade
don't you dare try and take my rook
get out of here let's trade a little bit
just a little bit
okay over here nice and easy no i
dropped my queen again push this pawn
bishop here was going to be coming soon
real soon what's the clock situation and
these these winds are not coming fast at
all
not at all
take that
okay
let's get my rooks finally doing
something queen trade
right here
what's the plan okay
let's go throw a pig on the second and
then follow up with some good stuff here
right here
night incoming
incoming here
right here no no no no right here
okay i could pre-move a bunch of stuff
this is leading to me
okay good one two three
just move back to determine 72 oh man
150. somebody has 150
and then there's 106.
wow is this the guy that i
came back against is this the same guy
it might be
oh
man oh knight d5 i keep messing that up
i think this is the same guy
yes it's got to be
come on
oh that's what they meant to do last
time it was a mouse slip on their part
i see
i see i thought g5 was a little weird
let's go get your rook here but hang on
your bishop that's why you threw the
king in the corner so follow through
follow through your plan now you're on
the night queen right here might be a
problem
get out of there night i might do this
in between her
whoa they didn't be tweenered me
okay i have the queen i have pressure
yes
let's see if i could lose this one
hang on
hang on it could still be lost
could definitely be lost okay push them
around
just a little bit
just a little bit hit hit um hit these
guys they're um they're pinned and stuff
grab here grab here that's actually
looking pretty good
right here looks pretty good chop
chop here bishop blocks pawn push
or just uh rook takes bishop would be
decent too
i'll do pawn push are they gonna move
they're not gonna move
a non-mover
oh no not a non-mover okay they get
something
i got something one pig is already on
the seventh looking for another one i
could take here even if it's defended
the work the rook is overloaded
checks
rook block bishop here
stay active pawn push a couple times
h pawn
coming up h pawn
attack the pinned pieces
pin pawn
no good solution back to tournament 90.
oh man
i'm struggling to find confetti
confetti's a long way off right here
ah what is the scoop here oh i know what
the scoop is here
i know the scoop is here negative 116
and now they're flying
now they're flying they're playing like
a maniac
they're playing like they've seen
millions of positions
and they only have 116
negative
negative land 116.
oh
i know what the scoop is i know what the
scoop is
let's go get that light square bishop
off the board these are extra difficult
to win
extra difficult when you start out with
like 20 seconds less
and you're playing somebody who's a
beast in disguise
a beast in disguise
oh rook is dead
oh i thought the knight should have
played there
all right let me let me hit that knight
can i get the light squares here
let's try this
and then this and then get pawn up or
something
or pawn push i should probably do a pawn
put now let's do this first
i want to keep my queen around there's
going to be a queen trade really soon
and open this up for my rook
and stay here i have this covered i
forgot that that was covered
let's bump up 20 seconds
20 ticks keep pushing pawn you know you
want to push rook takes pawn coming up
and i could defend
no tricks
where the tricks
right here keep pushing
queen right here
watch out for tricks
let's come back and defend oh no no no
no no
whoa stop that
don't you dare
don't you dare try and mate me
let's do this it's very scary
give a check
give a check here
defend six
don't have much time
i got the queen
this is still very difficult to win
though
very oh where is it
or is it can i get this
ah
uh-oh
where's the
where's the sneaky stuff quickly quickly
i got it yes
sneaky
ah
okay i'm gonna take those i have a funny
feeling that wasn't really a true
negative 116. i sniffed that one out
i think again
i'm sniffing them out
okay let's go bishop
let's get rid of that and get castled
bishop here nor not so fast
you don't drop pieces do you
let's go post up
post up take like this keep pressure on
the pawn
okay let's compromise the structure and
do what next
uh let's make sure the knight doesn't
get too excited about things that the
knight plays here i pin
king activity
bishop here we're here to defend upon
rook trade and it was missed come on you
know you want to resign they don't want
to resign
knight right here okay no back to
tournament 130. 2 30 is in top 232 26
180 nap three
nap already knows what i have up my
sleeve
already we have played this so many
times already
gonna take my knight
here we go
it's engaged here it's happening soon
very very soon
uh oh
pins pins everywhere
i still i really just want to still do
this night move even though it's
probably absolutely wrong to do it i'm
going to do it
i want to make it happen
make it happen
let's go here
i don't even know what that move is
doing
um
all right let's come back it's probably
could be taken next
let's do this if there's a check i jump
over here and get out of uh
sneaky stuff sneaky stuff was bishop
move there
okay now
let's move forward takes and i go like
this otherwise i went upon i'm getting
something here i think
still scary rook up and over is
available as well
do this
need some defense
give a check
let's do this i think this is uh good
too
now we'll take
and then get my knight involved
right here
okay let's take here right now
then throw this in i gotta watch out for
tricky stuff
let's do this just take my bishop would
you please you know you want to take my
bishop don't you
um whoa
that's uh okay the queens are coming off
the queen has to block otherwise they
get the rook
and they don't have any time
no time
there's night checks no okay i have that
covered
let's come over here and right here i
think would be a good spot to defend
stuff against the night
and uh well they don't have any time do
they no time no time no time no time
where are we at back to tournament 150
150 okay 3 10 is in first
wow 3 10 4 minutes and change
i'm a long way off from even top three
land
ah
okay
all right
let's go f4 knight f3 pile up on that
pawn okay they gave up their center
clean up queenside castle and throw my g
pawn in h pun okay i have the g file
let's come over here
making one threats
let's hit the queen pawn can't push
let's do this pawn push here or
bishop right here next i think is very
good
uh where is it let's try this actually i
have to get rid of that knight
let's come over here uh this this could
be taken maybe in some lines
let's back up
and let's get this knight into here or
here
where are the sneaky moves pawn push a
couple times within forks
forks open this up here i just want to
smash this open
okay they're on this
i'm on that
um what's the plan here oh i'm on the
queen
on that queen
grab that knight
they're in there to defend 23 um
my light square bishop needs to do
something
he was not doing anything i just want to
get it here
rook back over smashing through on this
square real soon
right now
where's the mate
mate in one two
back to tournament 170 308 can i get no
third place is
80 points away
oh i shouldn't have read that
oh that took the wind right out of me as
soon as i did that little math
calculation
i did basic subtraction right there and
then the wind was taken right out of my
sails
80. i couldn't even come out with the
word 80.
oh man
80
80 points oh man
what do you do
what do you do you can't do anything
about that okay break pins
stay focused stay focused
80 points away
wow
what a long road ahead it is oh
break pins before they kill you
oh
okay
this is going to be dangerous
very very dangerous oh knight takes
bishop is probably real good isn't it
let's try this
i'm gonna have to hang on to my light
square bishop i think okay i could um
oh in-betweener this isn't this is
working out i'm winning material now
i take the bishop with check or no the
knight just runs away
but i get a pawn at the at least and i'm
not going to take it with my queen i
want i'm going to hit it with my knight
again knight back takes takes knight 2
d5
and then take here
right here this is what i was talking
about
i don't want to take right there my my
knight belongs on f4 i could pre-move
that and then follow up with the fork
most likely
unless that king move is played no this
isn't still working because queen here i
take here
czecharoosky and then i get the queen
for free
or do i the rook has to take and i go
like this okay it is for free
time situation where are we at
where are we at here pre-moves
pre-moves pre-moves pre-moves
okay back to tournament they're down on
time
eighth
55 seconds it's going to end any second
here wow
somebody's up there at 3 18 oh
man
oh on top of all that
the game the the tournaments ending out
ending up here with somebody flashing
the bird
after all that
oh it's just not enough to take a
beating and be behind by 80 points
you have to deal with somebody flashing
the bird right at you of all players
that's the one player i did not want to
see right there
that's the one player you do not want to
see if you're down 80 points
okay
stay calm here you could do it 10
seconds left the queens are off but you
could still do it
no you can't
oh come on rook up and over
last hope rook up and over
kill the knight
give him eight kill a knight
grab a pawn
kill this guy
connected past pawns oh
let's go let's go are they gonna call it
it's saying complete
it's saying complete
oh oh no no flat adobe flash gambit
almost happened right there are they
going to resign
come on can i sneak in another win
it's saying that it's already lost look
at the clock
come on mate in two main two mate and
two just don't call don't call don't
call give me a win give me a win yes
i'll take it
oh
it didn't place me on the top ten but i
got that win
because they didn't call it
oh
what can you do
it's 356.
324.
wow
280 270
and then somebody way back here who was
way off from even 200 land
oh man
good games oh
close this thing out of